what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar we're back and today I
will be talking about Merlin and her
secret plan a plan that is only now
beginning to come to fruition 336
chapters into the seven deadly sins
story after the epic climax of the
battle between the sins and a demon king
you might have thought that the story
would be winding down but thanks to
Merlin and a dark secret that she has
been hiding all this time the story has
taken a completely unexpected turn and a
new incredible power has been introduced
the power of chaos we seriously need to
talk about Merlin secret plan why she is
doing everything that she's doing right
now and whether she has betrayed the
seven deadly sins or whether she is
merely trying to find a way to defeat an
even greater evil an evil that we still
don't know about if you enjoy the seven
deadly sins content on this channel
please leave a like to let me know it
definitely helps and if you happen to be
new to anime abroad don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications you have to
go through the trouble of clicking the
bell and selecting the option to turn on
all notifications otherwise YouTube will
not notify you it's just the way it goes
I want to give my sincere apologies for
not making a video about the latest
developments in the seven deadly sins
story earlier as you might know our
channel is blocked from uploading due to
a bunch of fake and completely
unjustified copyright strikes and
unfortunately even though the strikes
were fake and illegitimate YouTube did
nothing to help
they made us wait for the appeal process
to be completed without actually
intervening to stop the fall strikes and
they wouldn't even allow us to upload
new videos even though we did nothing
wrong for creators on YouTube it's
basically guilty until proven innocent
and that goes both for larger creators
and smaller creators for that reason I
ask you to please follow us on Twitch
twitch.tv slash anime uproar on our
twitch will still be hosting live
discussions of the seven deadly sins
chapters every week and we'll be
discussing other manga as well including
attack on Titan
hero academia black clover Demon Slayer
and more after what just happened to us
we realized that we can't rely only on
YouTube to provide content for you guys
YouTube can take it all away for no
reason in an instant and there is
nothing we can do about it
so for that reason please also follow us
on Twitch link in the description in
addition to that from now on we are
going to upload all of our videos in
audio format and you will be able to
listen to the audio as a podcast and
multitask or do whatever you like while
listening just search up anime upper
audio on Spotify Apple podcasts or
wherever you get your podcasts or you
can just follow the direct links in the
description that way even if YouTube
unfairly takes down our videos in the
future you will still have access to the
audio just search for anime uproar audio
or click the links and thank you all so
much for your support during this whole
fake strike situation finally of course
there will be spoilers for the seven
deadly sins manga in this video we're
talking about the latest developments in
the story way beyond the anime so please
proceed with caution you have been
warned okay now let's talk about
Maryland secret plan and the absolute
craziness that is the power of chaos as
I mentioned back in my video on Chapter
three three four it was clear to us even
then that Merlin had some secrets that
she was hiding and it is likely that she
has been hiding them for over 3,000
years after all she is still the most
mysterious out of the sins the one about
whom we have the least background
information and she is directly
connected to all of the major players in
this current part of the story including
of course King Arthur the mother of
chaos the supreme deity and this
mysterious Lady of the lake but then in
chapters three three five and three
three six a lot more brand new
information was revealed and this gave
us further insight into this new chaos
arc and into Merlin's secret plan back
in Chapter three three five we learned
at meliodas had to give up his demon
powers in order to destroy the ten
commands
which means that he now doesn't have to
leave the mortal realm and that
Elizabeth's curse has been lifted but
this also means that he no longer has
this immense power at his disposal aside
from that though at this point in the
story everything seems to be going great
for the sins except for Eskin or for
obvious reasons and it seems as if most
of the major problems have been resolved
and the story is beginning to wind down
but then Merlin teleports the sins back
to the magic lake where they had fought
the demon king and there Merlin uses her
magic including strange incantations in
her own language that humans cannot
understand or pronounce to summon
Arthur's body to that location she then
proceeds to speak to the Lady of the
lake
Merlin says that she has followed the
lady of the lakes revelation and that
everything is now in place Merlin also
refers to the Lady of the lake as a
princess the Lady of the lake responds
saying that it is time to say hello to
our master and in that moment
Merlin uses the magic of Excalibur and
of the lake to resurrect Arthur and
bring him back from the dead
an immense energy flows through Arthur's
body and he is suddenly he loved his
wounds and revived Arthur is confused at
first not sure where exactly he is or
what he was doing all this time and
Merlin explains that Arthur is the human
who has been chosen by the saint of
chaos whatever that means to become the
one who commands chaos to become the
lord of chaos suddenly Arthur begins to
change and transform his face contorts
and one of his eyes turns black that
leads us into chapter 336 with Merlin
telling Arthur to embrace the power
because it is time for him to awaken the
immeasurable magic within him
Arthur is confused and in a lot of pain
and the rest of the sins are confused as
well Hawks mama also known as the mother
of chaos also begins to act strangely as
Merlin declares that when the King
awakens he will release the seal of
chaos and chaos will return home to the
king Meli Otis
Rush's - Arthur in an attempt to help
him but this only infuriates Arthur
because Arthur thinks that meliodas
betrayed the sins suddenly the entire
world the whole physical realm around
them begins to shift and contort until
it resembles an absurdist or surrealist
painting everything begins to resemble a
nightmarish dream world the laws of
gravity and physics are completely
nullified but despite all of this Gotha
confirms that this is not an illusion or
a dream this is reality this entire
world which Arthur has created seems to
be attacking meliodas and meliodas is
forced to defend himself against it
against flying ghosts snakes dice that
look like they're from Dungeons &
Dragons and so on but Merlin then
embraces Arthur and calms him down
explaining the meliodas did not betray
him
Merlin tells Arthur that he must control
his power the power of chaos and as
Arthur calms down the entire world
suddenly goes back to normal again to
the complete shock of everyone else
present meliodas dan asks Merlin in a
serious tone what she has done to Arthur
and what exactly does she mean by this
power of chaos
Merlin explains that chaos is both on
impure and pure entity of both darkness
and light an entity that even the demons
fear and even the goddesses worship the
power of chaos is immense and it is
believed that chaos brought this entire
world into existence out of nothingness
and this includes the divine beings like
the demon king and the supreme deity
this power is directly related to Hawks
mama the mother of chaos and for some
reason Arthur has been chosen to command
chaos and become the king of chaos who
will lead Britannia into a new era it is
important to know that these revelations
pretty much confirmed that the
information about the mother of chaos
that was first introduced in the
prisoners of the sky movie is in fact
canon Merlin said something very similar
to this back when she was talking about
the great Oshiro aka the mother of chaos
in the movie at the very end of the
chapter meliodas asks Merlin why she
would unleash such an immense power that
is both a blessing and a curse
what is she plotting what are her true
intentions and motivations what is her
wish
but before Merlin can answer the lady of
the lake speaks again she asks the sins
to allow her to answer on Merlin's
behalf before she will tell them what is
the wish that Merlin made as a single
lonely witch who wandered the land in
search of chaos so what's next
this chapter basically confirmed that
the idea of chaos in the seven deadly
sins world is directly inspired by Greek
mythology in Greek mythology chaos is a
primordial being that was the first
thing to ever exist before the birth of
the Gods and everything else in the
world so is it possible that Arthur's
new power the power of chaos gives him
supreme power over physical reality is
it possible that he can defy the laws of
physics create new things out of nothing
warp and distort existing things and
just straight up turn every battle into
a living nightmare for his enemies that
would be extremely interesting and if
Arthur really is so powerful now then it
makes sense why Merlin would go through
all of this trouble to groom him revive
him and eventually turn him into this
king of chaos but then the question is
why does Merlin need this power why has
Merlin been searching for chaos all of
these years she's already extremely
powerful on her own so why did she need
Arthur to harness the power of chaos
it looks like the Lady of the lake is
about to tell us that very thing but if
I had to guess I would say that ever
since her own curiosity brought about
the destruction of her home city of beli
allowin the capital of the Wizards
Merlin has had a guilty conscience and
she has wanted to make things right back
when she tricked the supreme deity and
the demon king Merlin did not realize
that her entire city would have to pay
for her mistake and she probably grew to
hate the two divine beings and to plot
their destruction this is why she's
referred to as a lonely single witch
wandering the land in search of chaos
she was the only witch left the only
survivor from the capital of the Wizards
and she was searching for the power of
chaos in order
to defeat the divine beings who
destroyed her city the supreme deity and
the demon king
now that the demon king has been
defeated maybe Merlin plans to use the
power of chaos to also defeat the
supreme deity but wait there's more we
still don't know the true nature and
full extent of the power of chaos but if
we look back to Greek mythology and
Chaos's ability to create the world out
of nothing
then perhaps harnessing the power of
chaos will allow Arthur to wish belli
Alwyn the capital of the Wizards back
into existence
this would allow Merlin to finally atone
for her sins and who knows if the power
of chaos can revive the capital of the
Wizards perhaps it could also revive Big
Daddies sunshine himself the one and
only Eskin or also I've seen a lot of
people talking about Merlin potentially
being a villain now or a traitor but I
don't think that's the case Merlin
definitely has a secret plan and it's
definitely related to the power of chaos
but I don't think that Merlin is evil I
don't think she's plotting anything evil
and I don't think that the 7th of these
sins are ever going to be in danger from
Merlin whatever Merlin is up to I
believe it's going to have something to
do with her trying to make things right
in terms of the past and also create a
better future and a more peaceful future
for Britannia don't forget that Merlin
learned magic from the original go thir
the very person who sacrificed his life
to end the holy war from 3,000 years ago
I am certain that Merlin also wants to
end the conflict once and for all even
if we don't yet know exactly how she
plans to do it I can't wait to find out
more but in the meantime definitely let
me know what you guys think what is the
true nature of the power of chaos and
what are Merlin's
true intentions was her secret plan to
harness the power of chaos in order to
bring back her hometown is she going to
use chaos to defeat the supreme deity or
maybe both of those things or neither of
those things and something else entirely
hit me up with your take down in the
comments below if you enjoyed this video
and you want to see more $0.70 content
right here on the channel please leave a
like to let me know and if you happen to
be new to animal roar don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on
all notifications you can check me out
on Twitter and Instagram at anime uproar
for all the latest 7 Deadly Sins news
and updates and finally as I said at the
beginning don't forget to follow us on
twitch twitch TV slash anime uproar and
to check out anime upper audio wherever
you get your podcasts I don't want to
give a big thank you to all of our anime
uproar patrons who support our work and
make videos like this one possible with
all the problems facing YouTube right
now patrons are more important than ever
and we really appreciate it
special thank you to our pro hero tier
patrons including the one and only
Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason Wilson
Kings ell drous Fatih dalla beat Anatole
Cassatt's ki alpha do on hell crews and
team Sparky 65 and I can't forget the
ones who rise above all other clans a
massive thank you to our the 1 and tier
patrons including Ingrid ah
Alan Adam Mary Mack makoto-kun the world
Steelers and the school bus if you enjoy
our videos and you feel they provide
value for you please consider becoming a
patron even a single dollar will give
you access to our patron exclusive
discord and your name will appear in our
videos along with these legendary people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]